this is capital T
greetings citizens
welcome to the Coriolanus nine solar
thermal power plant in the heart of
district 5
this facility generates over seven
percent of our proud capital's energy
needs but did you know that you can
generate electricity from mere drops of
water I'm going to show you an
experiment that does just that
as we turn on the water it falls through
these rings and onto this mesh below but
look here after a moment there it is it
generates a spark of roughly 20,000
volts of electricity and there is no
power source here no turbine is in
traditional hydro generation in fact
there are no moving parts at all
we are creating electricity using only
the intrinsic properties of falling
water so how does it work well water
contains charged particles called ions
it has equal numbers of positive and
negative ions so overall it's neutral
however as the water falls there will
sometimes be a slight charge imbalance
with a little bit more negative charge
over here and a bit more positive charge
there under ordinary circumstances these
variations would even out over time but
not in this case here's the ingenious
part the mesh on the left is connected
to the ring on the right so if this mesh
becomes negatively charged then so does
this ring and now that ring will attract
the positively charged ions in the water
so the mesh on the right will now be
more positively charged meaning so is
this ring so what we have is a clear
separation of charge there's a
positively charged stream on the right
and a negatively charged stream on the
left
and the more the charge builds up on the
meshes the faster that charge increases
and finally when we have reached our
designed operating voltage of 20,000
volts electrons jump from the negative
rings to the positive ones through this
spark gap ionizing the air as they do so
we have created an electric generator
with little more than a stream of water
droplets no field of mirrors or enormous
coal burning plant is required in fact
with access to the right materials you
could even build this apparatus at home
thank you for your attention
we citizens of district 5 expand our
knowledge to better serve our great
nation love your labor take pride in
your task our future is in your hands
and don't forget to register for updates
from Capitol TV it's mandatory